I have this particular friend let's call
her Sandra
like many adult friendships Sandra and I
don't see each other often so we tend to
catch up via phone
for a while when Sandra would call I
would feel hesitancy at her inevitable
question so what have you been up to
because you see Sandra is the kind of
friend that always seems to be going on
a cool trip somewhere visiting a new
restaurant with a beautifully picked out
outfit specifically for the occasion or
going to fun events that I had never
even heard of
[Music]
one day as we spoke she kindly nagged at
me that her hour-long conversation had
been mainly about her and she wanted to
know what I had been doing with my life
since we last spoke
it was then that I realized that pretty
much every time we spoke I had
intentionally avoided the question what
have you been doing what have you been
up to because I felt that in comparison
to her life my life must look really
dull back then I allowed myself to fall
into the comparison trap and it left me
feeling embarrassed that I didn't have
anything interesting to share
now that I think about it anytime I felt
that my life was boring was often
because I was basing it off of a
comparison to others around me
[Music]
when I was a teenager in high school I
remember sitting on the front porch of
my parents home scoffing and thinking to
myself
my life is so boring my parents never
let me do anything fun they don't let me
go to parties or my friend's house and
we never travel anywhere or do anything
interesting
I can't help but Smile as I visualize
teenage Essie because back then she
didn't realize that just as seasons
change
so too do our lives have faces
I was trying to live the life of someone
else because it seemed to make them
happy and frustrated because I couldn't
achieve that
I now realize that I allowed myself to
Define boring based on the idea that
Society sold me about what it means to
have a good life
[Music]
oh my goodness
thank you
foreign
[Music]
I know that I talk a lot about social
media but it was definitely a huge part
of why I constantly fell into the
comparison Trap by seeing what others
were posting about their cool
experiences and the things that they
were doing and feeling like it was a
sort of bar that I should measure myself
up to
once I was able to let go of that I was
then able to find my own values and
redefine what it means to have a
meaningful and fulfilled life to me
I am incredibly thankful that in my job
as a hospice nurse I'm constantly faced
with the concept of death and dying
because it brings into perspective that
even though I'm still in my 20s it's not
about the time that I have left in this
world but rather the intensity of which
I live and Savor that time
I was recently listening to Dr Julie
Smith's book why has nobody told me this
before
and she defines values as the things
that you do the attitude that you do
them with and why you choose to do them
teenage Essie allowed her values to be
defined by the people around her in
order to fit in but it left her feeling
less than inadequate and empty
when I finally allowed myself the
self-compassion to acknowledge that if
my friend Sandra values cultural
diversity and exploration and that's why
she finds great joy and new experiences
that's wonderful she's living her life
according to her values and it doesn't
make my life any less Pinterest worthy
because I'm not living someone else's
life or doing things to show anyone
anything
I remember that when I had Facebook many
moons ago I constantly felt a desire to
post something interesting so that I
could sort of prove that I did
interesting things
but it got to a point that I remember
finding myself on the top of a mountain
overlooking an incredible View and my
first instinct instead of taking the
view in for myself was to grab my phone
so that I could post it to show other
people what I was doing
I have children now and as a mother my
values have changed just as I mentioned
that the seasons change
when Rudy has been ill or we've had
Financial struggles my priorities too
have changed
Our Lives will have ups and downs
and phases that we've never even
expected or saw coming
[Music]
I find much joy in being able to slow
down throughout those phases and enjoy
the mundane
romanticizing the routine the ordinary
I absolutely love weekends when Rudy and
I cook outside while the kids play and
we do absolutely nothing but just
breathe in fresh air
hear the birds sing and watch our kids
play
I love my morning latte Before Sunrise
when all is quiet
it's my me time
[Music]
and crazy enough I used to actually hate
this but I now find great joy in
cleaning and taking care of our home
because I've redefined my values
I Now understand what Dr Julie Smith
says when she says that values aren't
just the things that we do it's about
the attitude that we do them with and
why we choose to do them
so because I value my time with my
family I serve them with love through
the small things that I do
this means something like waking up
early so that I can read to my kids
before I go to work
taking our meals outside even though I
know it will be more work to clean up
because I find Value in time and nature
putting my phone away throughout the day
or during meals because I value the
people in my life and I value my own
mental and spiritual health
my days are filled with routines and
ordinary moments but I don't take them
for granted I know that my life is not
about the time that I have left but
rather the intensity of which I live and
Savor those moments
if you feel like your life is boring or
ordinary I want to challenge you with a
question
who defines that
and if you feel like you're not living
the life that you want to be living I
further want to challenge you to
consider what your values are
remember it's not just about the things
that we do but how and why we choose to
do them
I thank you so much for watching this
video if you would like to see more on
minimalism and slow living please be
sure to subscribe and hit that
notification Bell so you won't miss when
I post a new video
and if there's any particular videos
that you'd like to see in the future
shoot me an email or drop your
suggestion down in the comments below
again I thank you so much for your
support and I'll see you next time bye
for now
[Music]